[Music]
welcome back to our special Trump in
Asia Edition Tucker Carlson tonight
we're standing right now on the North
Korean border our interview with the
president didn't simply focus on foreign
policy or the decay of American cities
that you could fill hours of programming
in those topics the federal government
is being increasingly open about its
decades-long investigation of UFOs they
have spent millions of dollars and
officials admit now they've seen many
things they don't understand we decided
to ask the president about it
it was his semi cryptic answer watch you
gave an interview of their day what you
said you've been briefed on unidentified
flying objects are they are they real
well I don't want to really get into it
too much but personally I tend to doubt
it I mean you have people that swear by
it right and pilots have come in and
they said and these are pilots that have
met pilots that are into that particular
world but we have had people saying that
they've seen things I'm not a believer
but you know I guess anything's possible
spoke to a government official recently
who said the US government had wreckage
from a UFO in a facility on Air Force
Base were you familiar I haven't heard
them know I haven't heard that it has
not been within government has not been
a big thing but I've seen it I've seen
it on your show but I've seen it
I don't assume it's correct but they
don't I have an open mind Tucker thank
you for nowadays you can believe
anything right Nick Pope is a journalist
he once investigated UFO sightings for
the British Ministry of Defence and he
joins us tonight so Nick I thought that
was an interesting answer the president
said he had been briefed quote I don't
want to get into it but he's skeptical
the UFOs are real what does that add up
to would you say well first of all I
think it's absolutely refreshing to get
a straight answer from a president a
sitting president on this without
dodging the question without making some
humorous reference to a science-fiction
movie so that was good to hear I
understand
the skepticism I think everyone that
started off looking at this within
government starts skeptical but as you
say this reference to the briefing that
he has is very interesting and when he
says he doesn't want to get into this
does that reflect just that he's
personally not that interested or maybe
that he received some classified
information that he's not able to share
about all this we spoke to a u.s.
credible non-crazy US government
official who said categorically flat out
the US government has wreckage from a
UFO didn't say it was extraterrestrial
there was an unidentified flying object
and the US government has material from
that aircraft whatever it is that's an
amazing claim how would the president
not have heard that assuming it's true
well I I think yeah I I think that's the
big thing assuming it's true I mean I
would think that the president has
probably asked the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs firstly is there a threat here to
the United States and secondly resetting
that question aside what are we dealing
with I mean is this our own tech is it
Russia is it China or is it from
somewhere further afield I mean he will
have asked for all information held on
this and and will will be trained to
figure out what to do I mean he has said
himself something feels a little bit
different about all this with the US
Navy pilots and the radar operators now
coming forward so there is something
different and important and big
happening so what would you say since
you speak to a lot of people who are
involved in this not just in the
professional UFO questioning world which
I think most of us have a right to be a
little skeptical of but I've just you
know ordinary pilots and people going
about their business in government who
have intersected with these stories or
seen these objects themselves what is
the majority view about what these are
Russian Chinese American or something
else well I'm not sure there is a
majority view and and even within
government and I've
been here myself with the British
Ministry of Defence there were
conflicting opinions I mean look if if
the president would like more research
and more briefing I'm certainly happy to
help with that and I could probably
round up a couple of other former
intelligence officials from within the
US administration who've looked at this
and and we could certainly I'm sure you
know get some people who aren't afraid
to think the unthinkable and ask those
big what-if questions but look whatever
happens with UFOs this may happen on
president Trump's watch I mean we may
get with the current radio telescopes
certainly with the next-generation
telescopes we might get absolute
confirmation that there's other
civilizations out there and therefore
this might happen on president Trump's
watch he'll be the one who has to make
the announcement and what a historic
announcement that would be my fellow
Americans people of the world we are not
alone so I'm glad to hear he's
open-minded and thinking about this
because there has been an upsurge in
these sightings and who knows what the
future will bring there's something
terrifying about all that but we're not
in control as you often point out Nick
Pope great to see you tonight thank you
thanks Tucker